what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest one-piece chapter and
we got a lot to talk about from the
crazy reason to why buggy became a yonko
we got way more details on that since
the spoiler video to what's really
happening with the straw hats and the
final straw hat and more so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
these one-piece reviews and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
parking with it and smash that like
button always be a smashing pirate king
rather than a passing orochi and you
will be rewarded with youtube fireworks
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
and now without further ado let's jump
into it spoilers and all as those of you
saw the spoiler vid no the title of this
one is cross guild which is buggy's new
and amazing organization which we'll get
to in more detail soon katakuri is
present in the cover art here which is a
nice touch just as wano is ending we're
getting some pretty epic action the
cover story which i appreciate and these
cover stories really lend to oda's world
building and make the world feel alive
in a way that a lot of manga don't
sometimes it just feels like the outside
world is frozen when the protagonist is
fighting the epic villain of the ark but
in one piece that's never the case the
chapter starts with rhizo and shinobu
recovering from their green bull
injuries they definitely still look like
mummies and it's said that greenville
had a point about kaido's presence
keeping others at bay i said as much too
when he brought it up initially and now
that word could get out about bluton
being there it's hard to see momo and
friends defending wato against someone
like blackbeard or the world government
if they ever got the time to attack
kienenwon is here apologizing profusely
for being inquiry when it happened they
tell him not to sweat it though more
casualties were avoided by momo's
bravery and yes he was brave full props
for that but the gag is that aramaki ran
from shanks even while it looked the
most like momo might have scared him off
again momo isn't for a rude awakening if
another strong character shows up and he
thinks he's fine because of how the
aramaki fight went down they asked about
tsuru and kinemon lets them know that
tsuru suffered a nasty burn on her face
and i'm thinking to myself what's with
the burn marks in this chapter and in
one piece in general but more on that
later we get a very sweet moment where
turu blushes and says she always wants
to be by kinamon's side and kinemon
blushes smiling like an idiot saying
that she's as gorgeous as ever a great
payoff for this plot thread and his
happiness is contagious here oda did a
great job of illustrating kinemon's
overjoyed expression even inuarashi is
like even puppy love isn't that sappy
glad oda got to use a pun like that
while inu was still in the picture rize
was hilarious too wishing he were
popular and could get a girl like that
too but they just tell him to focus on
recovery carrich shows up asking why
she's been summoned she's pretty
carefree at this point and she's told
that she will be the next ruler of the
mokomo dukedom you get one of those
moments where she doesn't process it
right away and is like okay cool then
after a second she freaks out saying
wait what and although inu and neko
won't make the biggest difference
against a really strong opponent it
turns out that they will stay in wano
and serve as retainers to protect momo
which is good because as we said wano
needs all the added protection it can
get it's almost as if anyone luffy
crosses paths with becomes a major
player in history since neko cites how
she's grown very dependable after her
adventures with luffy and the others so
much so that she's definitely got what
it takes to lead the next generation it
seems like this is possibly oda's way of
handling some people's disappointment at
carrick not joining the crew by giving
her arguably the highest position she
could get and you know that she'll
probably appear again later as an ally
to help luffy so we have that to look
forward to as well carrot says some of
the others are way stronger and the
three musketeers come in saying yeah and
she can trust them to protect the
country for her wanda also agrees that
it was a wise decision because pedro's
will lives in her more than anyone still
though in a world like one piece where
the strongest usually rule it's a bit
strange to see carrot in the leader
position and it doesn't help that she's
only about 15 years old but let me know
your thoughts on this in the comments we
see zunisha reminding us that when
carrick shows up to help luffy for a
giant war down the line it's likely
zunisha will make its appearance again
and complete what it started in wano we
then get tsukiaki telling momo and
hiyori that he's their grandpa sukiyaki
is sorry and says momo really looks like
his dad and of course as we may have
expected after losing so many momo and
hiyori are so glad to find out they
still got their grandpa aka they still
got some family both momo and hiyori
shed tears and hiyori tells her grandpa
there's no need to apologize then we get
quite possibly my favorite part in the
chapter aside from the whole cross guild
stuff which we'll get into based on the
scabbard expression sukiyaki says he
takes it the rest knew it was him and
most of them are like yeah but it wasn't
their place to say anything meanwhile
kirimon is quiet we then jump into his
internal dialogue and he's shocked
beyond belief by the revelation i
definitely laughed out loud at this
moment i will definitely miss such
hilarious kinemon moments sukiyaki says
he'll pass on what he knows and then
he'd like to live anonymously among the
people kirimon says of course while
still thinking to himself how
unbelievable the revelation is on to the
straw hats just chilling like villains
robin then points out that pluton is
here and frankie is really affected by
that his veins popping sweat forming the
works luffy is really calm though for
his part and says he doesn't want it and
again the question comes up why would
odin unleash it from my view i see the
benefit for preventing others from
coming to wano if the weapon was
activated and ready to be used and not
just there for the taking plus we know
it's probably part of the prophecy and
all of the ancient weapons will probably
come up and be used by the end of the
story this is when shinobu comes in not
only fully recovered but as is pointed
out she got a glow up that sanji is
obsessed with she's skinny and tall
again adding another attractive
one-piece girl to the series and that is
always appreciated thomas says she'll
train with shinobu and asks if she can
join the straw hats down the line and
luffy says sure if she keeps up her
ninjutsu training i know some speculated
about tama coming with the straw hands
but i think most of us knew it wouldn't
happen still it's nice for her that she
has something to look forward to and
this seems to mirror luffy and shanks
from the beginning of the series who
knows maybe tama will also decide to do
her own thing before she ever joins
luffy we see caribou spying excited
about the pluton in wano news and he
knows a certain someone who would love
to hear about this let me know who do
you think he is talking about here even
though i'm sure a lot of people would
want this information we see momo going
through his day with a stoic look on his
face as they are planning out the
restoration of wano he finally shows his
excitement when he goes to see zorro but
no one is there the straw hats have
already left the building even yamato is
nowhere to be seen it's funny how they
said goodbye to everyone but momo and
kinemon the ones they knew the most and
as a result it would probably be the
hardest to say goodbye to them but i'm
guessing we'll get a usual one piece
moment where they run up to wave them
goodbye at least we then jump to kid
luffy and law and let's enjoy this
because it will be a long time before
these three ally up again if they ever
do law is practically a given for a
future team up but kid is more of a wild
card since the alliance is over they all
feel like they gotta take different
routes after all they're rivals again
law tells them to pick where to go while
choosing the most direct route himself
the other two choose the middle aka the
east direction with no real rationale
behind their decision kid wins a draw
and so it looks like luffy will be going
southeast it's interesting to see that
luffy throws being an emperor in kid's
face saying i'm the emperor and i should
be the best at drawing lots clearly
luffy has fully accepted his role which
is fun to see he totally could have been
called an emperor by others and not
really used the title himself but it's
cool to see him actually embracing this
title kid lumps luffy in with the other
emperors by saying something like you
arrogant emperors but then he says
someone angers him even more than luffy
and shows buggy's image in the paper
buggy looks awesome here and not only
that mihawk and crocodile are shown on
the cross guild poster as well you know
about this if you saw the spoiler video
but seeing the new images is great and
especially how the characters react to
the buggy news i love how luffy talks
about buggy in contrast to how the
others view him but at first luffy is
just shocked about seeing crocodile and
mihawk and how they're supposedly
working on their buggy we even see sweat
on the usually calm luffy's face sorrow
says he can't imagine mihawk doing this
but of course i'm sure that mihawk has
his reasons and besides many of us did
expect this and we're really hoping for
this law then says if he's capable of
commanding men like this then buggy's
definitely a worthy new emperor now that
alone makes him worthy of being an
emperor in law's eyes but it doesn't
stop there first luffy says buggy is a
[ __ ] and is confused about how this
happened but then kidd says crossguild
is also issuing bounties on marines
which i love just as much as the fact
that mihawk and crocodile are now on
buggy's crew and keep in mind even
whitebeard was down to work with buggy
when it served his interest at
marineford so it's not that hard to
believe that mihawk and crocodile would
do the same even if it turns out to be a
temporary partnership but back to the
marine bounties and kid pretty much says
what we're all thinking and i quote now
those navy dogs have to wash their backs
too the hunters have become the hunted
end quote and now we get to impatiently
wait for hype bounty reveals like kobe
sakazuki's garps and so many more they
point out how the world really changed
when they were on this isolated island
again going back to how oda makes his
world seem so alive the rest of the
world doesn't just freeze as events are
happening with luffy i also really love
how law gives kids crew a copy of the
road poneglyph saying they earned it i
love the respect shown between these
pirates even though they are rivals then
killer and kid talk about how if they
want to stay ahead in the quest for the
one piece they gotta go after the man
marked by flames is it sabo is it a new
character i have no idea but oda gives
us another thing to wonder about in the
comments of the spoiler video someone
even said that this might be the man
shanks was talking about with the five
elders meaning the man marked by flames
and that's funny to me just because i
feel like the fandom's opinion on who
shanks was talking about has changed so
many times with every new bit of
information luffy doesn't know who kids
talk about and law seems
uncharacteristically serious and
mysterious implying that he knows
something kid just laughs though saying
it looks like he's ahead of luffy then
we catch up to yamato yamato is on the
roof as momo and kinemon find out in the
spoilers it wasn't clear if the straw
hats already left without her but now
it's clear that we didn't see them leave
to see yet yamato says yeah i've made up
my mind i'm about to head over to luffy
and the gang it's finally time for me to
live like odin did heroic and free and
so it obviously looks like yamato's
joining but the funny thing is nothing
has really changed in this chapter in
regards to yamato yamato wanted to join
before too and made that clear and we
still didn't see luffy officially accept
the offer since he woke up so i'm
hopeful but in my view it's still not
confirmed until yamato is on the straw
hatch ship sailing with them and wano is
out of sight and we'll hopefully see if
that's the case sooner rather than later
but that is it for this chapter the
buggy and mihawk stuff was amazing the
rest was a good unwinding of wano plot
points and we are about ready to set
sail again in the next chapter if you
did enjoy this review and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
parking with an end smash that like
button always be a smashing king rather
than a passing orochi and you will be
rewarded with youtube fireworks if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
by the way in the spoiler video i asked
you guys to vote on the anime uproar
instagram about who has the higher
bounty luffy or buggy now and out of
thousands of votes 74 said luffy meaning
that buggy would have a bounty lower
than 3 billion in this case i'm of the
opinion of the minority since i find it
hard to believe that buggy as a yonko
and after all of this would have a
bounty less than kid in law but let me
know your thoughts below in the comments
and if they changed after this chapter
what is your guess for buggy's new
bounty and is anyone else wondering how
he can pay for marine bounties i'm
thinking to myself how awesome would it
be if he found captain john's treasure
finally and that's how you can fund all
of this awesome insanity can't wait to
find out but while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords admirals mythical zones and
much more linked to that is in the
description on screen right now if you
made it to the end of the video thank
you i really appreciate you and until
next time see you space cowboys